U.S troop reinforcements have begun
arriving in Germany as fears over
Russia's troop build up on Ukraine's
borders increases their first contingent
of 2 000 additional U.S soldiers
arriving near Frankfurt overnight with
others touching down near Poland's
border with Ukraine White House says the
troops will protect Eastern NATO members
from potential Russian aggression but
Russia says they're worsening already
high tensions in the region AWS
Alexandra fundaman explains what's
behind the U.S decision
thank you
American F-15 fighter jets arriving in
Estonia a Danish frigate deployed to
support nato in the Baltic Sea more and
more allies are sending troops to
Eastern Europe it's not a choice it's
the must says security expert winology
NATO has to prepare for every possible
military scenario it is not unrealistic
for instance to think that Russia could
create a border incidence with Estonia
to distract attention from an invasion
in Ukraine
to be prepared the U.S alone is sending
1700 troops to Poland and a thousand
strong unit to Romania France wants to
send soldiers to Romania as well the
neverlands is considering deploying
fighter aircraft to Bulgaria so too is
Spain while the UK made its patch troops
to Estonia and danish fighter jets have
already arrived in Lithuania compared to
Russia's NATO presence in the region is
still relatively small but as the
Kremlin continues its build up around
Ukraine NATO is strengthening its
defense posture according to Secretary
General stoltenberg the alliance is even
considering deploying new battle groups
in addition to the four multinational
battalions already in place in Estonia
Latvia Lithuania and Poland
the four battle groups were deployed in
response to Russia's annexation of
Crimea in 2014. NATO members argued then
that they cannot ignore russia-breaking
International rules and undermining
peace and stability and now NATO is
confronted again with what they describe
as aggressive behavior and its members
are responding with reinforcements
Putin's goal was to have fewer NATO
troops close to Russia's border but so
far he has produced the exact opposite
the current crisis policy analyst Albina
Ranson suggests has galvanized the
alliance Russia's actions especially
since 2014 have sort of given NATO a new
impetus for for its core mission for
which it was established to secure
Europe to deter others from invading or
potentially
destroying the security order in Europe
and yet that doesn't mean NATO will send
combat forces to Ukraine if Putin
decides to strike in fact the alliance
has already ruled a doubt but many
members are increasing their economic
and military aid for Ukraine with the UK
and Poland promising a new security pact
it is unlikely that the arrangement will
be something like nato-ish where the UK
and Poland would have a duty to defend
Ukraine I think what we will see is
cooperation in terms of military
training financing making sure Ukraine
has a military means also to defend
itself
according to Nato it is all about
defending its members that is the reason
for the reinforcements the alliance says
Russia denounces them as hysteric and
destructive both sides however say they
are open to more talks
of them all let's bring in DW
correspondent Nick Connelly in Kiev Nate
these NATO deployments to some countries
in Europe what difference do they make
for Ukraine
well I think if anything Rebecca they
just show ukrainians the value of being
in NATO something that isn't on the
cards anytime soon or even in the middle
term for Ukraine right now this is all
about the symbolism of the US reassuring
especially smaller NATO members with
smaller militaries on that Eastern flank
on the border with Russia I think for
Ukraine it doesn't do much Ukrainian
recent weeks has heard that all it can
expect if Russia does invade our
sanctions against Russia maybe more
weapons deliveries and financial aid but
no NATO military boots on the ground
here in Ukraine to help Ukrainian Army
as you rightly point out Ukraine is not
a NATO member but these are of course
NATO troops we're talking about just
talk us through if you will Ukraine's
relationship to Nato
so Ukraine Got a very
um kind of elusive pledge that at some
point it would be able to join NATO back
in 2008 at the Bucharest NATO Summit but
that was never really clearly defined
there was no road map to joining
obviously since then Russia has been
making very clear that it sees a NATO
membership for Ukraine as a red line as
it is U.S lawmakers have been discussing
giving NATO giving Ukraine rather the
seats of a NATO plus member which would
allow it to get a U.S arms more easily
other kinds of support they've been
various kinds of Western training
missions for Ukraine's military and then
more in the way of bilateral military
aid for Ukraine by the US by the UK
recently supplying those first lethal
weapons from the UK recently but there
is no commitment by NATO to defend
Ukraine and as I said before Ukraine is
well and truly on its own if Russia were
to invade
now this of course all comes uh in
context of the Russian troop build up
next to the Ukrainian border on the
other side how do the numbers compare
I think this is a really important point
because you know there's been a lot of
criticism from Moscow of these U.S troop
movements but they are tiny compared to
what Russia is doing in the same region
so these are essentially 2 000 new
troops being transferred across the
Atlantic from the US 1000 being moved
from Germany to Romania this is pretty
poultry if you accept the claim from
NATO General Secretary stoltenberg
recently that Russia is sending 30 000
fresh troops to Belarus alone these are
exercises being held between Belarus and
Russia in that country that also lies on
Ukraine's borders on top of the hundred
thousand Russian troops or more along
Russia's border with Ukraine so these
really aren't comparable in terms of
scale and this is very much a symbolic
move but nothing that really changes the
balance of force in this part of the
world
I think I just wanted to also gauge the
the atmosphere there briefly if you can
How concerned are ukrainians right now
well there's a bit of a kind of
Disconnect between the world's attention
on Ukraine and lots of ukrainians
seemingly going about their daily lives
without too much of a change but when
you when you talk to them they often
will tell you that they are slowly
coming up with plan B's you know taking
cash out in case uh issues happen with
the banks here they have to leave in a
hurry so there's a bit of a
schizophrenic sense of a desire to keep
on going but preparation increasingly
for the worst
all right Nick thank you DW's Nick
Connelly and Kiev